org slash history
next on american history tv retired
colonel thomas holden a former marine
corps pilot talks about his
participation in operation frequent wind
the 1975 evacuation of americans and
south vietnamese allies from saigon
after it fell to the north vietnamese
the national world war one museum and
memorial provided this january 2020
video
and now i'd like to proudly introduce
retired marine corps colonel thomas w
holden
colonel holden was commissioned a second
lieutenant in the united states marine
corps during his college graduation and
proceeded directly to pensacola where he
was trained as a marine pilot
he was designated a naval aviator in
december of 1968
and received further training in the
ch-46 helicopter at marine air base
tustin california
colonel holden was deployed to vietnam
in april of
1969 and on his second southeast asia
tour he participated in the saigon
evacuation flying the last 11 marines
off the roof of the american embassy on
the morning of april 30th
1975 which this evening will be hearing
more about
he is a graduate of the army war college
in carlisle pennsylvania and the
national war college fort mcnair
washington dc
he later served as the marine corps
chair on the faculty of the naval war
college teaching national military
strategy
he moved to kansas city in 1993 and was
assigned as the commanding officer of
marine corps support activity kansas
city and he later retired from the corps
in 1996.
ladies and gentlemen please help me in
welcoming colonel thomas holden to the
stage
thank you
well thank you very much it's a pleasure
to be here
and uh to talk to you tonight
about uh some of my experiences
and uh as i start i want to talk
first to say that
i want to speak on behalf of all the
marine pilots that participated in
operation frequent wind
in operation eagle pole which occurred
just a few weeks before that when we
evacuated the embassy at phnom penh in
cambodia
77 helicopters took to the
air and accomplished that mission and we
had some great marine corps pilots uh
making that happen
the
unfortunately like a lot of operations
it didn't go without a mishap early in
the frequent win saigon evacuation
just before they started with the
helicopter extraction
we lost two marines at guard post one
near tonsinu air base
and a corporal mcmahon and lance
corporal judd were both killed instantly
when a rocket
hit their guard post
we also lost a ch-46
during the evening and i'll talk a
little bit more about that
lieutenant
shea and captain nystul were aboard that
aircraft they were lost at sea we did
get the crew
rescued
i'd like to start a little bit about the
history of that time we had a
election not long before the evacuation
and
president nixon had vowed to end the war
in
vietnam and he was true to his word he
and dr kissinger worked very hard at
doing that and in 1973
they signed a
sort of a peace with honor type treaty
similar to what we had in korea
and the north would stay north the south
would stay south the american
fighting forces would be removed our
prisoners of war would come home
and everything was supposed to stay like
that
the north vietnam anytime a violation by
the north vietnamese would mean a
complete reversal and nixon said he
would send the bombers back in
and attack again and i think that
quite honestly they believed him
reports were that the north vietnamese
were terrified of nixon
and
listened to every word he said
the problem was when he resigned
and left the white house
the north vietnamese immediately took
action and launched an attack
along the
main corridors of
south vietnam coming south
i had returned to westpac
to the first marine aircraft wing in
okinawa and i was assigned to hmm 164
a ch-46 squadron
however this works maybe
i'm not getting it to make
not coming forward
not real good with technology
um
so anyway i was with this uh age 46
squadron and i had no no really
indications that we would be going back
to vietnam we were very happy with doing
our mission
you got a funny thing on the screen here
there you go
okay
thank you
that's the h-46 you see there
that we used on the evacuation for the
46 side and we were happy campers we
were flying all over the pacific this
was taken in the philippines
heading out to a carrier and everything
was going really well for us and then on
april 4th i had been gone for a while
came back to the united states for
a short vacation
and when i got back
we were told immediately on april 4th to
get everything you have
loaded up your flight suits all your
equipment and then fly out to the uss
midway
which was sailing south it would be
about 70 miles at sea
we would land on it and then that would
take us down to subic bay the
philippines
and from there we would do some
additional work
and so every aircraft in mag-36 marine
aircraft route 36 which was stationed in
okinawa
uh 46 is wise it was hmm 164 my squadron
we had 14 h-46s we had a bunch of hueys
we had four cobras
all flew out to the midway and landed
and we spent two and a half days
doing nothing but eating in the galley
having a great time it was a great ship
i was very happy to be on the midway and
then once we get to the philippines uh
like they usually do they said get on
your aircraft and fly off to subic there
to qb point airfield and we did that and
then the next day the uss hancock
here's another picture of the h-46 doing
carrier-borne operations
uh very similar to what to what we did
the h-53s was the other aircraft we were
with
the h-53 is a heavy hauler can carry a
lot of tonnage a lot of passengers
this is the uss okinawa
it was out there with us and it was
sailing around with the hmm
462
and that was the ship we embarked on the
uss hancock
we got a board there in the philippines
and you can see there we had a complete
h-53 squadron 463 hmm 164
composite with some cobras and hueys now
the oddity was our squadron when we left
okinawa
we were we didn't have enough pilots
back in those days we were short on
pilots
so we we brought some guys that had
flown the 46 maybe five or six years
earlier and they were flying co-pilot
which is rather dangerous
but it was the only way we could get
every aircraft going and get it onto the
ship
the other thing that was odd is that
we didn't have the senior leadership
that most squadrons had we had three
majors
one had come from uh headquarters and
maintenance squadron my major whitey
maytag a wonderful man
who had been the maintenance officer at
headquarters of maintenance squadron
we had a cobra pilot the junior major
dick hooton
and then we had another major major
steel
who was also with the cobras he had been
their operations officer and then we had
a safety officer from the air group
the question was who's going to be in
charge and go to meetings and do
everything you have to do aboard ship
and so they all got together
and we decided that we'd make the junior
officer
the commanding officer
and the way we did that and the reason
for that is he had a letter with him
that was very valuable
how many marines are
former military do we have in here
tonight quite a few
yeah
you all know what office hours are
non-judicial punishment
he had the letter that allowed him to do
that
and so for good order and discipline we
needed to be able to if we had a trooper
that didn't stack up and do the right
thing we had to have the ability to
hold him accountable
so we made him the commanding officer
the maintenance officer from pam's 2436
he took care of the maintenance issues
and worked with the ship the best he
could because we didn't take
a lot of maintenance parts with us
we were supposed to be just gone 10 15
days and come right back
and so
we didn't think we'd need a lot of stuff
and by that time the aircraft were
running pretty good
and then the
ops officer from the cobra unit he
became our observations officer and then
the senior major became the laundry
officer he uh
he sort of backed off on some of this
stuff he didn't really want it he
thought we were doomed to failure and
was really a downer
so
we didn't want to see him a whole lot
and if we didn't
but we lived aboard ship and the other
thing at that particular time was the
h-46 community and the ch-53 community
of helicopters
we were not the best of friends it was
the best way to say it uh we respected
each other
but in vietnam back in the day
the h-53 cost a lot of money
and if they got shot up
they had to really answer for it
because we didn't have a lot of them and
we needed that aircraft for the heavy
lift if we lost an h-46 no big deal we
had tons of them we could always replace
it and replace the crew but the h-53s of
course at night at the club you can
imagine
how we sort of let the h-53 people know
what we thought
so
they kept us out of a lot of the
information that we needed
anyway we sailed
south
and
we loitered off the peninsula of long
tau
and we sat there and sat there and sat
there
waiting for the south to fall and things
slowed down
and they on
april 10th they diverted us to
cambodia
and we went over there and the operation
order was set
and the 53s were going to run that
mission completely because the distance
from the ship to the landing field in
phnom penh was 130 nautical miles
and the h-46 would have to refuel when
we got there in order to get back to the
ship so what we did is we ran search and
rescue off the coast of cambodia should
an h-53
h-53
go down in route
or if one gets shot down we could go in
with a team to rescue the crew
and rescue the the aircraft if we could
once cambodia was done and it was done
really
efficiently
what is my numbers here
i think there was about 289
americans and third country nationals
that came out and that was it
we didn't bring any
cambodians out
it was interesting in the fact that they
wanted to stay they didn't believe that
they should leave their country
it was theirs and they were going to
stay and see what they could do most of
them unfortunately were killed
and
didn't didn't survive the takeover and
when phnom penh collapsed
we went ahead on the ship
went back around and
it was 289 people came out of that
evacuation
and we moved back to vang tao
south vietnam
and the ships circled in an area there
we had two battalions with us
uh second battalion fourth marines and a
battalion from the ninth marines i think
it was one nine
and there was a big discussion whether
we should have an amphibious landing
in admiral wittmeyer who i'm going to
talk about a little later who was a
wonderful wonderful senior officer who
was the commander of the seventh fleet
said he would have nothing to do with
putting more americans back into vietnam
our mission was to get everybody out
and so that came to an end real quick
like
and we kept sailing around and every day
we'd get up around four o'clock in the
morning expecting today's the day we're
gonna go
nothing would happen we'd sit ready to
go until about two o'clock in the
afternoon and then we just go back to
our bunks
and wait and wait and wait and then the
next day come along and same thing over
and over
well on april 29th
and actually the 28th they started
taking rockets in at tonsinod air base
and the c5s 141s and the heavy lift air
force aircraft could no longer do
evacuation
of the vietnamese and americans out of
that site
and so they decided at 0-700 on the
morning of the 29th to stop all
fixed-wing evacuation
and activate the frequent wind operation
order and do everything by uh helicopter
this is the american embassy you can see
here every pilot had a picture of this
and um
i'm going to oh this is it i think
right there is the landing zone on top
of the embassy for our h-46s
uh the hell the big aircraft had to land
down here this tree had to be removed
and we got it down within about 12 hours
the marines that were on site there at
the security unit
and uh they were ready to go
um
outside
i can tell you right now the street out
here
and other streets around here
uh was wall-to-wall people everybody was
trying to get in everybody wanted a ride
to freedom
and it was just a
mess
the other problem we had was
communications
uh i my son who some of you know also
served in the marine corps
he used to call me and he read a few
books about vietnam
and he'd say that's all fiction i what
i'm reading isn't it and i said well it
depends on what you're reading he said
well how did you fly at night
and i said well it was easy we just took
off and we it was a moodle at night it
was pretty easy but if not we'd use our
navigation aids to get to where we
wanted to go
and he said but how'd you do that
without night vision goggles
he was just astounded by that
and then he'd say well and you went out
into the jungle to get a medevac how did
you know where that guy was
i mean did you have gps
and i said no i said we did have a
distance
dme it was called distance on the attack
and radio that would give us so many
miles out and then we cut it off the adf
radio the two needles when they crossed
we figured we were within about a five
mile area and we'd look for a strobe
light on the ground and if we picked up
the strobe we knew that's where we had
to be and the marines on the ground knew
to take that strobe put it in a helmet
and as we went around a big circle once
we saw the strobe we knew we were on a
glide path to come in and pick up the
wounded individual and you didn't have
to worry about seeing a whole lot
because generally speaking the marines
on the ground would try not to put a
tree in your glide path which would ruin
your whole day and
they wanted to get out as bad as we
wanted to get in and out so it worked
out pretty good but my
my son just to this day he still has a
problem with that because he's always
had night vision goggles on his helmet
he's always had gps to tell him where to
go and how far it would be to get there
anyway we started flying oh the other
inch
issue communication
no cell phones we didn't have cell
phones
we had a uhf radio
vhf in a high frequency that was never
used because it would shut down the
engines
uh dangerous
but the uhf was primary and we'd leave
the ship
and we'd have a helicopter direction
center tell us give us a steer towards
vietnam we'd go that way we'd see the
land we'd pick up the air force
direction center which was called sign
cricket
and cricket would tell us where to go
and all this good stuff well we started
the operation
we were supposed to start at 12 10.
and confusion was when is el hour
the navy and the army
have different definitions for el hour
and so it was really screwed up to begin
with and so by the time we got there was
about three o'clock in the afternoon one
thing happened that was really
unforgivable but it did in those days
a message came in to say we're going to
start this whole operation right about
noon
well the guy was going off shift he was
leaving another guy was coming aboard
the shift on this on the radio station
there on the ship so this guy took the
flash messages filed him away the next
guy came in went through stuff but he
didn't go through the flash message
basket
until about an hour or two later
and there was the message said the
operation starts at 12 10. well right
now it's three o'clock
so you can imagine how we had to
scramble and everybody on the ground was
a little bit ticked off that no one had
showed up
when they were supposed to and it's just
because we didn't get the word correctly
we thought it would go like phnom penh
the h-53s started out beautifully they
would go two aircraft at a time they
went in to tun snoot where they were
going to pick up the vietnamese some
americans and start bringing them out to
the ships
we had 44 naval vessels
in about a 10 nautical mile
area it was really packed out there was
a beautiful sight to see
i don't know if we'll ever have that
many navy ships in one locat location
again
we had the uss midway of course the uss
hancock uss okinawa the uss coral sea
another aircraft carrier which was
carrying fixed wing
aircraft and the oddity about the midway
the uss midway had 10 air force
helicopters aboard the air force flew
these aircraft down from thailand udor
and thailand all the way down and around
the peninsula aerial refueled and then
came aboard a navy ship this had not
been done before
and it's a terrible time to practice
this when you need everybody working
but
they did a marvelous job and the navy
after about a day learned how to work
with them
they do have they do have peculiarities
and uh
some are good some are bad but we made
it happen
and everything was going well they did
they went in and did their part of the
mission
my mission that day as it started out
the same was going to be just like
non-pin we had the corpsmen doctors and
everything i went to nabe
and at nabe i was going to orbit in this
case there was an aircraft that went
down needed extract and that kind of
mission
as we sat there from three o'clock to
about 4 30
it was time to come back to the ship
because we only carry about an hour and
40 minutes of fuel
had to come back get gasoline
we landed on the hancock refield went
back and it became very clear at that
point
that this
line of evacu people needing evacuation
was endless
i mean it looked like it would never
stop
they were lined up for miles it's like
going to a trump rally
and
it was one of those things like we just
said to ourself
this is crazy so what we started to do
we made a command decision we said we're
not going to use this search and rescue
mode anymore we're going to start going
into the embassy picking up people and
we went back and forth back and forth
you came in picked up people went back
refueled then you went in again it's
called daisy chaining
and you tried to keep the two aircraft
together best you could
the we always landed on the roof
and it was sort of neat the first couple
times in the security guard came into
the aircraft
he asked me he said do you guys want
some pistols
and i said no i've carrying one i've got
one he said no do you want some pistols
and he showed me this box full of
pistols everybody getting on aircraft
was frisked and they were taking the
weapons off these guys
and other stuff and i said yeah here's
my helmet bag fill it up
and he did
and everybody came out of that operation
with a full bag of uh nine millimeter
brownings uh 32 cubs 45 automatics some
of them very very nice
and um
so it was that was one of the bennies
but uh so we kept flying
the weather
weather was really
bad uh i guess it started out okay but
the ceiling kept coming down and the
operation plan called for going in at
6500 feet outbound 5500
and uh if you've ever flown in a
helicopter anything above 3000 feet is a
little bit nerve-wracking
because that's a long way to fall if
things come apart
and uh so what we tried to do is we went
down early down to about 3000 feet and
we stayed there
below what the other traffic was and
that we finally talked to the 53s and we
said you're wasting a lot of time
climbing all the way up to that altitude
just get your people come up to three
thousand feet cruise climb and go on out
to out over the water
and eventually they did
the other problem was the air force
cricket who was trying to keep track of
everything the loads of people coming
out
who's where what's going on
their communication wasn't too good and
they weren't ready to handle 77
helicopters
it just wasn't
plausible
and a couple of the cobra pilots who
were down low
circling around the city
literally took over they said we know
which landing zones are open
we'll guide you in contact us and they
took over and then the operation really
took off we were able to be more
efficient
and
it worked really it worked really well
at that point
another thing that was operational
concern
again my squadron we didn't get all the
briefings that the h53s got
and one of the questions in the 53s
didn't get this answered how many people
are we going to be picking up
no one had a clue
i mean it was just
could go on forever and so that was a
big problem
the other big issue was
is anybody going to shoot at us
no one knew
one reason we went to 6500 feet
inbound was because we thought if
they're going to use the sa-7 missile
we'd be we could see it coming at us
early enough and and take defensive
measures against it which weren't much i
mean at that particular stage we didn't
have a whole lot of anti-missile
capability
but
those were issues that would really
get to us as we were flying along
especially when it got dark
and then that was the other one are we
going to fly at night
we had asked to fly at night to train
because most of us hadn't had a night
flight for probably 60 days and
especially off a carrier at night it's
really difficult to see sometimes if you
can see it all
and you wanted to be ready
and
but we were not allowed to do that the
ships didn't want to operate at night
and so that was turned down and then
like i said the weather really got bad
and that was starting to force everybody
down lower
the other issue that became a real
problem that night as we came out
was finding fuel
you got 77 aircraft out there flying out
to these ships and they have to get gas
each time they come out and land
we didn't have enough refueling points
one of my friends who was flying in age
46 went to a landing ship dock which has
two spaces in the back for helicopters
he was ready to
literally flame out and lose his
aircraft so he landed right next to the
ship in the water
and sat there bombing up and down in the
waves until one of the aircraft getting
fuel would leave so he could jump up on
the deck and get fuel
there was a cobra that night
one of our
cobra crews who literally could not find
a place to land and they crashed into
the sea both pilots got out and were
rescued by a boat from the uss kursk
but refueling was a big big issue
the embassy here was going to be a
secondary
point appointed departure for evacuation
it was supposed to be americans only
and
we figured there might be about 200
americans coming out of there
it turned out there were 2 000
vietnamese there
and not just americans but they were all
mixed in the ambassador
was an interesting fella
ambassador graham
and
i don't know what he was thinking or
what he intended i do know he was
conflicted because he had lost his son
in vietnam who was killed
a couple years earlier
and i think he had a real passion for
vietnam
and all these vietnamese that had worked
for him worked for the united states
he really felt that he has to take care
of these folks
they were his responsibility
uh he figured and he figured rightly
that if they get captured by the north
vietnamese they would either be killed
or sent off to education camps
so he he just kept
delaying his departure
jerry berry who was with hmm 165 he flew
lady a09 went in twice to get the
ambassador
ambassador refused to go up to the top
deck there to get into the aircraft and
jerry got back to the blue ridge which
was the command ship the admiral and
everybody was out there to greet the uh
ambassador all these vietnamese get off
and
the admiral went up and asked jerry he
says where's the ambassador he says he's
refusing to leave
and literally he just wouldn't come out
of the embassy and go in fact he was
really upset when the rockets hit tons
and we had to switch to helicopters he
drove all the way out there had a staff
car drive him out there to make sure
that he was being told the truth and
then he came back in
uh finally at 0 4 58 in the morning
lady ace
zero nine with jerry berry flying and he
flew 18 straight hours a little over
that uh came in landed
and told the
ambassador you better get on board now
this is you're gonna have this is the
last aircraft you'll get a couple more
for the rest of your security detail and
that's it
and finally the ambassador took the flag
everything he needed got on the aircraft
and departed
the problem we ran into
and no one knew this
is that when
jerry got back to the command ship the
blue ridge
he is called he uh first called uh the
tigers out i've got the tiger that was
the call sign for the ambassador and
when he landed on the blue ridge he said
okay tiger's out we're done
and everybody took that as a signal that
the operation was complete
and people at this point already had
started shutting down because of
exhaustion uh you've got to remember
most of us had been up since four or
three o'clock the previous morning
and some longer than that the
air force guys had already shut down
they have a very strict
air crew
requirement
and so they were they were all tied up
and done
i had come back at a little after 10
that night
my wingman and i had landed
and when we were sitting there refueling
on the hancock before we could get off
the deck we looked off to our right and
we saw this flash
and that's when the tsar aircraft
with bill nystal and jj shea flew into
the water
we knew there was an accident
we had one problem i couldn't get the
refueling not everybody that was
refueling us had stopped to watch what
was going on and i couldn't get the crew
chief and the refueling crew to break
the hose loose
my wingman could get his got his loose
and he flew over oh it couldn't be more
than 60 70 yards from the ship and he
landed in the water and was able to see
the two crewmen because they had their
pen flare they managed to get their pin
flares out
and they were shooting their pin flares
at the helicopter so he was able to land
in the water drop his uh
cargo door and drag them in they both
had broken legs and a lot of other
damage to their bodies but they came in
and we saved those two
so
when they got back on it became very
apparent that
air crews were getting really exhausted
and so they finally shut us down told us
to get out of the aircraft
and they uh told me and my wingmen to go
down into the ready room
and so we went downstairs
and uh the aircraft were
the
uh
46 the blades fold up like a cocoon and
they put them away in a in a slash they
called it and we went down to the ready
room and they said there was a rumor
that there were americans at a place
called canto
60 miles south of
saigon
and i said well
more than a rumor i said what kind of
real facts do we have about that
and they didn't know they literally
didn't know
but we started breaking out the maps and
they wanted us to go down there and
search for these people and i said
that's just really insane because down
in that area where they wanted us to go
there really was no
electricity was limited to small
villages and i said i'm not going to be
out there just searching around but we
spent about two hours
looking at that we also spent a lot of
time doing the accident investigation
because we knew that was going to be a
problem
and
let me one more slide here i wanted to
show
this is what it looked like at night
when we took off with the weather
that's the age 46 this is what the roof
looked like at night that we had to land
on
pretty small target to hit especially in
that kind of weather but uh kept us
alive kept us thinking all the time
we got back in
to the ship
my co-pilot was steve cook a wonderful
man
stan hughes was a crew chief
and uh i can't remember the gunner's
name they'll come to me and we were
sitting up on the flight deck
around six o'clock in the morning now
most of the guys were smarter than me
and that's not impossible most of them
are always smarter than me and they went
to bed
they said screw this instead of hanging
around they went to bed so we were just
walking on the flight deck back and
forth and a guy comes running up and he
says we got a problem we got 11 marines
left on the roof at the embassy
and i looked at him of course saying
sure you do
this this can't happen but they said you
got to get that aircraft there was one
aircraft on the flight deck they said go
get it
and go
and so
the crew chief stan hughes i said is the
aircraft ready to go he said yeah so he
got it buttoned up and everything
steve cook got in there i got in there
and away we went
and we were sort of numb
literally numb because we were so tired
and we started going inbound
just like this aircraft here was a
yankee tank with 22 callsign swift
and
the problem was
over there along the coast you get these
squall lines you get thunderstorms that
just pop up and they go up about 15 000
feet or higher
and we thought oh boy how are we going
to get through there we knew that the
line might be
half mile to a mile wide
and we were trying to think about back
at flight school what they tell us about
penetrating squall lines and
thunderstorms and we finally made a
point that we were going to go through
it
which we did and
the hail in there was so hot bad
the h-46 has windshield wipers which i
always thought was a nuisance but the
hill was so bad that it blew them off
the aircraft
i don't know where they ever ended up
and we but we did break out it was about
a half a mile
and we used so much fuel doing that i
knew fuel was going to be a problem so
we went straight ahead went up the
saigon river
and stayed right about 500 feet saw the
rooftop came in landed picked up the 11
marines and that's where something else
interesting happened um
there's several books written about this
and most the books embellish a whole
bunch of stuff
and i was called one time and they asked
questions
and i couldn't remember very much and i
was trying to they asked me well you
they say you
landed you picked them up and then you
landed again and your crew chief says
that was because you had to get your gas
mask on because the marines have popped
their cs gas containers to hold off the
vietnamese trying to get to the roof
and i thought boy that doesn't sound
right because i don't think i ever
checked out a gas mask
but i didn't think about it very much
and i let it go
there's a there's a i told one fella
here i said there's a great
video out
by the american experience pbs american
experience called the last days
and i'm watching it
and son of a gun what happened was
when we landed we picked up the 11 guys
but the last guy getting on an aircraft
over the ramp in the back fell out
and so when we got up about five or six
feet off the ground getting ready to go
the lead leader of that team yelled at
the crew chief to yell at me to say no
sit it back down which we did and that
guy finally crawled back on the aircraft
so we had all 11 on board so that
answered a question that had been
burning in my mind for years
and then the other thing that burned in
my mind
a lot of you probably see it maybe you
see it at the exhibit here it shows a a
huey
sitting on a small
rooftop
with a whole line of people coming up to
it and getting on it
that's sort of an iconic picture
but that is a air america c.i.a huey
and that's on top of a apartment
building and he's taking his family and
his wife's family
out of the country with them
so that's what that's all about and some
other air america people landed there to
get other people out of that apartment
house
but
that was usually several days before the
final evacuation
anyway we lifted off and we headed down
the saigon river
and
that day was a beautiful sunny day
and everybody was along the riverbanks
waving like this to us you know of
course we put our hands out and waved
back at them
and i got to thinking this is really
surreal this couldn't be happening but
they were just seemed to be so calm
and no one shot at us they could have
because when we landed
the embassy was literally surrounded by
the t-72 tanks
and it was surrounded by the
their aaa and aircraft guns in the back
of these trucks and they tracked us in
and out and of course told the gunner
don't ever don't even think about
shooting at them because we don't want
to make them mad
but uh i knew then there was something
strange going on about the rules of
engagement
anyway we flew back got to the ship got
to the uss okinawa
we left the rooftop at about 7 53 in the
morning
and got back to the okinawa at about 8
20 refueled went over to the hancock
this time i made sure that i went to bed
i didn't hang around i just said
everybody get out of here go hide
someplace
and we did
that night over a thousand 54 hours were
flown by the air crews
682 sorties that's in and out
the evacuation of the dao the defense
attaches compound over at tonsinod air
force base
they took out 395 americans
4
475 vietnamese
went out
at the u.s
third countries lifted out of the
embassy
978 americans came out of the embassy
and third country nationals and another
1
120 vietnamese
so there was a total of 1300 plus
americans evacuated on that mission
5595
vietnamese
and third country nationals
ending up in the united states was over
138
000 vietnamese from that from the
evacuation by sea air and across the
border into thailand
the sad part is we did lose our search
and
search rescue aircraft with captain
nystal and lieutenant shea
i wish that could have been different
the irony there was if there is one
bill nystal had just shown up in okinawa
and
there were some people that just didn't
come he knew we were short on pilots
his wife and kids had just showed up in
okinawa
and we told him to stay behind but he
came and then that night the question
was what mission do we give this guy
because we had no idea what the outcome
of this operation would be
and we said the search and rescue
chopper would be the best place
well it turned out that it wasn't
um today i look at some of this stuff
and i'm thinking that um
let me see what we got here
one more here
this was the hanger deck by the way of
the hancock
and let me tell you a good story here
there's a i don't know how many hundreds
of people are there
um
this became a real issue
uh we're going to be at sea for four to
five days on our way back to the
philippines
and you have to feed them and when i
talked i met with admiral wittmeyer
when i was an instructor at the national
war college later in my career
and
we were sitting down talking
and i asked them what's the most
important thing you thought about out
there you know like
people shooting at us do we have enough
military aircraft we can this and this
he said no he said i was worried about
water cups and food
and i looked at him i said what do you
mean
he says these people have to eat the
same diet
they've been eating i can't afford to
give them steak and ice cream and
everything we eat
i need rice all the rice i can get
and then he had people every every ship
had coca-cola machines
and every can was kept the empty can and
cut in half and used for a cup so when
you got off a helicopter coming on board
the ship you were frisked
for any contraband
you were given a cup
and then we had the galley set up a
special galley for these folks of rice
and a few other items that they were
familiar with because you had to do that
and that was one of his biggest concerns
one of the other great concerns was
what do you do with them for five days
the engineers naval engineers on the
ship have my greatest respect
because one of the problems is
you have to have a way to relieve
yourself
all those people
and they went out on the hangar
elevator that goes up and down and they
built these
miraculous latrines
i guess you can call them for men and
women
separately
and it was quite an invention that they
came up with but they were able to solve
that problem
but then again you had boredom
and
captain eagle
a ch-53 pilot one of my favorites
he came up to me and he said
well i got an idea
now eagle was known as the tuba man
and ray kroc owned the
san diego padres
and at the first game of the first of
the season
tuba man always had to be there
because he played the tuba
for ray kroc
and his tuba was a bright green
camouflage in some places
and he went and got the tuba
and he would literally
walk up and down the aisle here
and these little kids
they would jump in behind him like a
snake following him
and he did that for about an hour one
day
and he was going to quit
he was getting tired
and the captain of the ship came down
and says
that's really great and he said thank
you he says i'm going to quit and he
says no you're not
he says you're going to be here for the
next six hours
by the time we got to
uh subig bay in the philippines he his
lips
but the the kids just gathered around
him they loved him and he really saved
the day
but that was quite a mess there
swift 2-2 where are you today i just saw
this in a magazine about well less than
a month ago this was the famous aircraft
i flew in and out with
it's at davis mothen at the boneyard
uh it's in a cocoon i'm i'm glad to tell
you that
that aircraft is going to be uh
soon to be relocated to the castle air
museum in atwater california
they're going to repair it and put it
back into
original colors and everything and it'll
be a museum piece
but that's where it is today and that's
how it looks
that's how i feel someday when i get up
so uh
oh yeah one last epitaph
uh when we came back we got off they
kicked us off the hancock the hancock
brought their a4s back on their a7s they
were glad to see helicopters go because
it's a real insult to a
fixed wing carrier to have helicopters i
mean they just
my god how low can you go
and uh they were just so happy to see us
leave so we left and we went down and
landed at uh qb point beautiful air
station in the philippines and
we needed to get back to okinawa i got
14 aircraft crews and i'm working
different angles what ship is heading
back that way we can get on and
get home
we got on the okinawa
we're sailing back to uh
okinawa the island
on the uss okinawa
where we got the aircraft spotted i'm in
the lead aircraft
the rotors are turning everything's good
i can see on the horizon
the
silhouette of the island coming up and
at that time
as some of you know me i had a little
girlfriend there and i was eager to get
back and all of a sudden
as i'm sitting there the ship does one
of these hard 90 degree turns and then
another 90 degree turn out of the wind
and i'm yelling at the crew chief take
the chains off do something we got to
get off this ship and immediately got
the shutdown signal
and a thing called mayaguez had happened
where a bunch of people had taken a u.s
ship freighter
and that's a whole other story but we
could not get back to okinawa
so we were forced to hang out at the
pool at qb point here for 30 days
and
san miguel was 25 cents
the famous qb hot dog was another 25
cents and i can't even begin to tell you
how many hot dogs and san miguel beers i
had for those 30 days
but nobody drowned while i was there
so that was the good news
and uh and that's my story i hope you
enjoyed it if there are any questions
i'd be glad to
answer them
folks as a reminder
tom you're going to get two rounds of
applause tonight folks as a reminder you
are welcome to come to either side of
the stage add a mic or if you're unable
i will come to you
this is my real hair by the way
good
from the audience
tom what was your fuel situation on your
last when you left the embassy going
back to the carrier what was your fuel
situation
desperately low
if you look
at the last day's
video from american experience which was
interesting and they had some pictures
of the last 11 guys in the back of the
aircraft
great picture i don't know how they got
it
and one picture
was forward to the picture of the guys
and you could see in the cockpit the two
warning lights
and the warning lights come on at
roughly 400 pounds of fuel aside
and
the question we had and the sad part is
and i love the navy
maybe
you can't get them to turn a ship around
sometimes
and we called them and we said we were
short on fuel and you better turn around
if you don't want us to go in the water
and good thing it was it was daylight
but we landed with about a hundred
pounds of side we just barely made it
back
to the ship and okinawa was the closest
one that's why we went there first
but yeah fuel was a big problem and it
was a problem during the evening
when we flew
i could tell you one other good little
side story
then i'll take your question as we're
coming back
i got up one morning i had the early
morning uh flight
and again i told you there's a whole
bunch of ships i mean we had the hancock
the midway and all this stuff
and i take off and i'm flying and all of
a sudden i look i see something strange
right in the middle of this fleet
was this cruise ship
how it got there i don't know but
everybody on the cruise ship was out on
the rails
waving and looking and they were
they couldn't have been more than 100
yards away from the midway which is a
great sight to see anyway especially if
you go to san diego today it's a
wonderful museum out there
but these people on a cruise ship are
right in the middle
and i'm thinking how did they get there
because you just can't penetrate that
they had to do it at night somehow and
just odd
and when i went back after that flight
they were gone i don't know how they did
it
okay yeah any other questions
so the marines that had been left behind
at the embassy that you went back and
got was
was that because
i mean people had stopped because they
knew they'd
um you know that tiger was back or like
did you ever learn anymore about how
that something like that could happen
good question i read it i've tried to
read everything i can get my hands on
basically
the whole operation was stopped when
they said tigers out
and then but there were still a few
aircraft flying that made a few last
trips before those marines went into the
embassy locked the doors went up the
stairs to the roof
and
they were up there about an hour and a
half to two hours
and i think they were getting a little
nervous they were calling out to the
ships but again all we had was a uhf
radio and the ships were out to sea
about 60 miles
so getting contact was almost impossible
and
i think when they what happened and i
really can't verify this i've talked to
people is that
on the okinawa uss okinawa
their unit
did a head count
and the question started probably going
around saying where are these guys
and someone said well the last time we
saw him and they were at the embassy and
they couldn't find anybody that could
verify they'd come out so that's how we
sort of
ascertained that that's where they were
you are welcome nasa follow
up have you kept and do you know who
those marines were and have you kept you
know found any of them or
no i've i know who they are
i was told one of them lives here in the
uh i thought in paola but that didn't
turn out like that he didn't and i've
not never been able to
make contact with them i've contacted my
crew chief and the gunner i have not
been able to contact the
co-pilot
but
yeah it'd be nice to it'd be interesting
to talk to them because i'm sure they
could add more
to what i can't remember
of course they're getting my age and
they probably can't remember either
so
our next questions from the audience
toward the back
i'm sure most of us or all of us have
seen the
film that shows people pushing
helicopters off i assume an aircraft
carrier what's the deal with that
uh
when the evacuation or when things were
getting really dicey the south
vietnamese
early on decided they better get out
and
the south vietnamese military had the
hueys
they had chinooks they had some other
private planes and they started flying
and everybody knew we were out there in
the water out in the sea
and they were coming out in small boats
hundreds of boats
and
so they came out to the ships and we had
some space and we landed
some of them
but as it kept growing the numbers were
growing we couldn't keep them all
on the chinooks that were fairly decent
the navy had a crew that would go up
with a saw and cut the rotor blades off
throw the rotor blades in the ocean and
we take the whole
carcass of the aircraft down into the
hangar deck
huey's
the huey aircraft that cia had
we saved a lot of those but it turned
out to be worthless because they were
made by kawasaki industries in japan
and the metal that they used to make it
with the siding and the skin of the
aircraft
could not get an air worthiness
certificate in the united states
it was a co-produced aircraft
so you'll see a lot of pictures where
literally people landed got out and then
they took the aircraft and then they
shoved them off the side of the ship
a couple of things and i think one story
i was told about the
bill nystal who was perished out there
in the aircraft accident
he had spent his day
when they would come out the chinook
would come out drop its family lift up
hover off to the side of the ship and
the pilot
would then
blow his
door off the side of the aircraft and
then he'd sort of stand there and take
the aircraft and push the cyclic this
way and he'd step this way and he'd go
into the ocean
and bill would try to go over and pick
him up the problem we had was a lot of
the vietnamese didn't swim
when they did that and the families told
us that we couldn't find them
that
that would probably be a problem
the other problem we had
is that
we didn't have
navy seals maybe people that could do
water rescue
we had the equipment but we didn't have
people that could enter the water
and so if a helicopter ever comes over
the top of you
the rotor wash coming down on you
literally pushes you underwater
and they said that bill
probably drowned maybe two or three
people that afternoon
and it was weighing heavy on them
and so uh
but yeah that's what happened we
couldn't bring them all back
uh there are some interesting stories uh
what would you know
what kind of souvenir did you bring back
from the war
and a friend of mine said well i brought
a helicopter back
you know and uh he literally did
he uh
the captain of one ship he had they were
pulling these barges
so that they could land these aircraft
out on the barges and when the rescue
was completed the captain told bill and
sublette and another guy okay cut the
barge loose sink it and the navy air
boss on that ship said can you fly that
chinook and bill said certainly and he
said can you fly the huey certainly so
they went out there on the barge did
what they were told got it prepared to
sink and then they flew the aircraft
over to the ship
and so
the captain of the ship thought those
things were left behind in the waters
with the with the barge
well the problem was the captain that
as we were going into civic bay saw
those
and got really irate and told them both
to get those aircraft off this ship so
they did and they went into qb point
well qb point
wasn't going to let them land
because they weren't us aircraft
so they had a real problem and a real
dilemma and finally they landed
the military police arrested him
they took both aircraft away
and parked him the chinook was big
enough we made an office out of it for a
while because to get it back to the
state's bare
transit line the freight
hauler it was too expensive for him to
put it on a ship and bring it back he
didn't have that kind of money
but that's that's true we got rid of a
lot of aircraft
this will be our last question
i'm curious the parallel picture of the
earth side view of the 46
with the foothills in the background
is that laguna coming in and out to
tustin
that's the philippines that is the
philippines okay yeah
beautiful beautiful country to fly over
i don't know if we have any world war ii
guests here tonight that were at leyte
gulf
but leyte golf was one of the most
pristine most beautiful places i've ever
seen from the air you can see 50 feet
straight down in the water
it's just gorgeous
it was beautiful
folks this wraps up our program tom will
be available in the lobby if you have
additional questions as always on behalf
of the national world war one museum
memorial thank you for joining us and
another round of applause for colonel
tom holden
thank you